what are the ins and outs of unlocking
this iPhone show it's just one phone
there's devil's advocate for you well
the FBI started off in this case saying
they wanted to unlock just one form that
was a form that belong to the government
noe and was used by a dead terrorist and
as he was dead he had no privacy rights
but once we started to dig into it it
turned out that there had been dozens to
hundreds of similar cases where the FBI
wanted Apple and others to create tools
to get out stuff and they weren't
willing and clearly this was the
photogenic case that the FBI thought
they could use to battle down the door
now it's an enormous expansion of
government surveillance powers because
traditionally in America if the police
got a warrant that give them the right
to Luke but it didn't give them the
right to compel the suspects neighbors
or other people to help them and in
particular if you take the rights to or
other a company to provide a weakened
version of its software there is a big
problem about who else will want that
weakened version of the software that
golden key and what they're going to do
with it
what is this golden key how would that
work if you've lots something you've
locked it haven't you well on an iPhone
or an Android phone or any other
electronic device the lock that a user
can deploy to encrypt his data or her
data using a password is largely
implemented in software on the device
and the software can be updated and it
typically is once a month or so to have
patches against whatever security
vulnerabilities have been discovered so
if you can somehow subvert or coerce the
update process you can turn the update
into a golden key and this for law
enforcement must be very thrilling but
for everybody else it's disastrous
because if people start worrying that
software update might give the
government or a foreign government
access to their stuff they'll turn it
off and the consequences of that for
Internet security could be really really
serious so I'm thinking of a real world
non digital example of this this like
you've gone and bought us
if with very strong metal walls and then
the company who sold you the safe can
turn those walls into jelly well yeah if
the company has got a secret 12 digit
engineering access code for use by its
own technicians only you know when they
attend a customer who is safer a
banker's branch manager has died and
didn't write down the combination and
the safe manufacturers technician can
then enter this 12 digit magic gourd and
unlock the bank vault
well that's very convenient if you're a
safe manufacturer but then if the FBI
says we want you to give us the safe
magic code because that's one of these
safes and the Chinese embassy and you do
so right and then that 12 digit code
gets out because you know mr. Snowden
puts it in his latest batch of
revelations and then the Chinese and the
Mafia all have this magic 12 digit code
then you're absolutely hosed and there's
an example of that from juniper routers
juniper make routers you know the
telephone switches for the internet and
some years ago it seems the NSA got a
backdoor in one of these routers
presumably because they got one of the
people to get a job at juniper or they
subverted somebody who was already there
and we learned from the Snowden
documents that this backdoor existed and
what happened then was that the Russians
and Chinese and others weren't looking
for it and found it and now juniper
routers half of whose outputs are sold
in the USA are being used by bad guys
overseas to attack America far more than
they are used by the American
intelligence agencies to attack targets
in China and this is blowback this is
what happens when you start abusing
infrastructure and other trustworthy
facilities for your own intelligence
purposes it can come back and bite you
and that's one of the reasons why for
more senior American intelligence
officials hidden Roberts and so on are
now against encryption backdoors a
number of agencies have dreamed about
and sometimes implemented no bus
capabilities nobody but us and there is
a very long history of these nobody but
us capable
Bertie's suddenly become kept becoming
capabilities that many nations had
another example is the atomic bomb when
the Americans used it in 1945 they
reckoned it might be decades before the
Soviets figured out how to build one
but of course within three years the
Soviets had it too and we had the
nuclear standoff of the Cold War here in
the UK though that's not going to affect
us though is it I mean you know this is
an iPhone in America and it's American
laws we're talking about the FBI case is
really really critical for Britain
because of the investigatory powers bill
that's now going through Parliament now
the investigatory powers bill gives the
Home Secretary the power to all their
communication service providers to help
law enforcement with warrants now in the
old days that just meant that British
Telecom had to let in the chap from GCHQ
with his crocodile clips that you know
attach a tape recorder through online
but nowadays that most communication is
being handled by Facebook Google Yahoo
Twitter and so on it's very very
different and the bill has the facility
for the Home Secretary to give a secret
technical capability notice to a
services company saying that they must
make available a certain rights Apple
surveillance capability now because
foreign firms objected they're putting a
clause and they put a clause in the
draft bill which says that there's a
defense if it's technically impractical
to provide the facility you don't have
to do it and also if it's against the
law in the company's country of origin
you don't have to do it but now if the
FBI succeed in compelling Apple to
provide a golden key for Apple products
in the u.s. corrodes and Apple then make
that golden key and use it only once
then cereza maiya can put a secret order
on Apple in the UK saying we would
really rather like to have one of these
golden keys to please kindly deliver it
to GCHQ within 30 days or go to jail and
you may not tell anybody that you've
given us this golden key and what's
going to happen then
is that the French will do the same do
Apple give a key to the French well
perhaps because the French are a
civilized country and a permanent member
of the
national security council and so on and
then the Italians will want one too and
now hang on a minute signor Berlusconi
was in cahoots with the Mafia for many
years and abused state facilities to do
the Mafia's bidding do you really want
to give it to the Italians well perhaps
given European structures you have to
and if you give it to the Italians then
the Greeks want one and then the
Egyptians want one and then the Saudis
want one and pretty soon just about
everybody except the government of North
Korea has got a golden key to your
iPhone we'd like to thank audible.com
for sponsoring this episode of
computerphile they've got over 180,000
titles to choose from so if you like
books go over to aural comm slash
computer file and there's a chance to
sign up for free today I'd like to
recommend I was which is Steve Wozniak's
biography many of you all know he is if
you like the computer file half of the
pair that started Apple most people have
heard of Steve Jobs I'm sure you guys
those computer files will know who Steve
Wozniak is so check out I was sign up
for your free trial at audible.com slash
computerphile
thanks once again to them for sponsoring
this video I have been speaking to
people in the big service companies and
an example of the thing that they suffer
and that really bothers them is this and
it will read or hose your Google and run
our shell code so we should get a shell